strong words from the governor and the
department of education
calling ccsd superintendent dr jesus
jarrah quote dishonest
this all has to do with the issue of
school funding oracle mana has more on
what's causing the controversy and how
ccsd is responding governor steve
sisolak and superintendent of public
instruction
joan ebert are not mincing words this
all revolves around statements made by
ccsd superintendent
dr jesus dara about assembly bill 2. the
bill would have let the school district
take leftover money from schools and
give it to the district
to help with the budget crisis right now
the nevada legislature is in a special
session
figuring out ways to deal with the
state's 1.2 billion dollar budget hole
dr jarrah had said the agenda item came
from a request
from the state department of education
but state leaders say jarrah is
misleading the public
the governor said in part quote being
superintendent of one of the largest
school districts in the nation requires
leadership
and leadership requires honesty
unfortunately that is not what we get
from superintendent jarrah
clark county students staff and family
members deserve better
superintendent ebert also said in part
quote it is incredibly concerning that
superintendent jarrah is again blaming
the state
for his actions instead of taking
responsibility for ccsd's request to
sweep funds
from individual schools to cover the
district's funding deficit
now this is what dr jarrett said at a
virtual town hall yesterday when asked
about assembly bill 2.
let me just clarify because there was
never support as i stated
in the state assembly in the senate and
the assembly
i was very clear that i was going to
work collaboratively with the building
principals to
to balance the budget it was not the
recommendation and it was not ccsd
bill the bill was not ccsd's bill
ab2 assembly bill 2 was presented to
lawmakers over the weekend it's unclear
if it'll move forward we just got this
statement from ccsd on behalf of dr
jarrah he says in part quote i want to
work hand in hand with our state leaders
to find the right solutions
for maintaining fiscal responsibility
while at the same time giving our
children
and their families what they need to be
successful
it is in all of our best interests to
work together and that is my goal but we
have to get to a place
of true collaboration to read the full
statements from dr
jarrah governor sisilak and
superintendent ebert go to 8newsnow.com
in the newsroom orca mana 8 news now